[Music]
well welcome into part two of bonnaroo's
changes for 2023 I'm Brad there's Barry
and Lord Taco hi guys
hi play game play game what is that
thing in the corner of your screen there
Taco is that part of your whole your
Minecraft world that you've
developed and are conquering on
this is for the twitch stream it uh
shows just random graphics and stuff
Barry I uh I jumped into Taco's twitch
stream the other night I still have no
idea what's going on
I'm kind of glad go ahead go ahead what
what what PBR was I on when you just oh
it was deep you were deep
so we said uh how far away are you from
a thousand check-ins on
oh yeah what's it called grinder for
beer what is it called grinder for beer
or untapped untapped yeah all right so
he's like he was like 500 none of us
500. he was like you were something
crazy away and we we did the math if he
drank
25 beers every day until I got there he
will have hit his his like five thousand
I don't remember what the number was I
don't remember I am uh currently at 869.
that's what it was yeah that's right so
you need to get to a thousand and you're
you're a hundred you were 150 away when
I left I just got to do 25 a day that's
nobody it's doable it's doable wow that
we can have so that we can have the the
show the next show we do can be Lord
tacos thousandth check-in of PBR are you
guys I can celebrate a thousand chickens
are you gonna have to cut back to make
that number yeah
take a couple days off I might be you
know a thousand and ten I don't know I
wanted to point out something that I
noticed after our last show you know
we've bragged about Russ uh for people
who were just listening and he's our web
guy he's created our website which is
awesome created our merchandising uh
does all of our Social Media stuff but I
think we we discovered a new Talent uh
last episode Brad really I do tell I
don't think I even know what was it I
think Russ is now our the what podcast
hype man
tight man yes yeah hype man yes because
when you look at me you think hype you
think hype he got me all all ready to go
for the show and you really you do you
do rev the engines you send thighs the
quiver well you know there were some
comments I know a video last week yeah
what were they
people wanted to hear more from me but
more Russ I don't know how we could fit
more of you in I don't know well
I'll show you hey yeah man I kind of
like being just a a background character
flying the wall I think you said it best
last week when you when I'm like the
coffee guy on time
yeah sitting back there what I love
about that guy is that he just laughs at
literally everything you know
I love that everything's hilarious yeah
everything's hilarious uh So speaking of
last week's show uh the whole point was
you listen to it you have any questions
anything that we might have missed any
sort of follow-up that we want to get
through and we ask your comments at what
podcast.com and then at uh the what
underscore podcast on Twitter and on the
social media so let's get into it
um you want to go through some of the
questions because we got a ton and I'm
sure that Corey and Brad didn't answer
all of them huh uh only they I think
they missed yeah we got quite a few but
they asked answered most of them and uh
especially thanks to Corey
um for reaching out this weekend uh to
make sure that happened they've been
great by the way yeah I mean they were I
thought that show was great they were so
forthcoming and and answered everything
I don't you know that's right they
didn't uh didn't run away from anything
didn't backpedal any of that so and
they're answering these questions so how
do you want to do this I sent you guys
the question and answers as well I mean
I I hate to be ready you did of course I
did but you didn't okay so that's all
right
I knew that you would not oh oh look
you're there okay
all right all right here we go okay
let's just start with let's start with
uh next next first question what about
group group for the chat group for the
shaft last year way out in BFE with very
limited support almost similar to how
Bob schepek I don't know what any of
this means I know um so basically the
question is what about decoupling
sinaroo from camping does each camper
need a camping pass or is it still per
vehicle in group
what was Corey's answer to that yeah and
his second or third point was the ice in
there and Corey's answer we're bringing
back the second entrance to Center Route
which he said on our show they're adding
food beverage and Ice to the group area
uh he said this is the first he'd heard
of the long lines of ice so okay there
you go they're dealing with that so here
you go
uh yeah and uh but by the way shout out
to Nick uh because I actually do know
him or know of him I've talked to him
before yeah another fellow Volkswagen
guy and his his last name is
g-w-o-z-d-z but I think it's pronounced
and please correct me I think it's
gavosh
wait a second g w o z d-z yes that's not
a typo that's that's how he spells it
but I'm pretty sure it's pronounced
gavosh guads yeah that's a rock solid
name right there that is a great name
yeah yeah man man what if it was like G
wads well that's how I would his name is
but well feel free to uh comment and
correct us it's got it wrong but I think
that's right it's first name Nick it's a
guy that that is surrounded by people
with quote-unquote radio names like
Thrasher and you know
I would go
g wads is fantastic that's an awesome
name be a good fan heavy metal band name
I love it
um okay so then there was one really
really long one and I'm not going to get
into all of it but let's uh go with Bill
Rich's questions you want to go that one
first yeah well that would be second no
okay so there's camp we got one from
Kent well I know this is a really long
one okay go ahead so quite because it
comes up with uncoupling back to the
uncoupling question by the way if you
don't know what we're talking about you
should probably go back and listen to
the marathon that was last week's
episode before their AMA they're doing
it ask me anything on Reddit that uh
some of these questions might get
answered as well uh we're just trying to
clear some of the clear some of the road
before we get there yeah I'm glad you
brought that up that's going to be on
the 21st and I asked Corey about that
this morning as we were emailing back
and forth with these answers and he said
they don't have a time yet uh just check
with their social media their socials
and they'll let everybody but no but
they're gonna do an AMA like you just
said on Monday the 21st they're going to
come out with their official
announcement about all these changes on
Thursday the 17th they were just cool
enough to jump on with us Brad Parker
and Corey Smith last week to give kind
of a heads up and so that uh
what is happening today could happen
people would have what about questions
yeah right and we got some good
questions got some great questions so
all right so questions arise with
uncoupling this is from Bill one what
value remains with VIP camping two will
VIP camping even exist and will it
remain closer to sunroof than ga3 will
VIP still have both camping and sunaru
dedicated Lounge areas and four will
there be dedicated VIP entrances into
centeroo now this was the part that I
will be totally honest probably Twisted
me around more than any other part of it
because uh I I'm not very smart it turns
out plus I think that they moved a hill
so it's these were probably the
questions I had the most so what was
Corey's response to these
so Center root ticket Remains the Same
pit viewing lounges access to the mound
as they call it I like the hill much
better and we plan to expand those
amenities a bit there will be no VIP VIP
camping anymore but there are a couple
of options for similar experiences
they're calling it area 931 we know it
lovingly is Camp nut butter
I'm gonna guess that's going to be the
the trees uh backstage camping it will
offer a limited number of primitive car
camping with included showers air
conditioned restrooms and amenities
they're gonna have free pitch glamping
and power RV in that section that I want
to stop you real quick okay let's go
backwards for a second this is a really
big you know I think that we probably
buried the lead in the um in in last
week's episode VIP camping is the most
effective of all of them and what you
know of VIP before is not going to exist
anymore they're moving VIP to where we
used to be right is that what I'm is
that I'm right to assume that's what I'm
hearing that's area
931 and yeah that is Camp nut butter and
it's not the mound it's the hill uh just
to be totally clear yeah we gotta talk
to them about that okay so and and to
Lynn I just say this and I'm not selling
tickets here but that is legitimately
the greatest spot on the farm yeah and
we have been so insanely lucky for 15
years to be able to be right there it is
absurd how fantastic that spot is so if
you're one of these guys who thinks that
VIP camping will not have value anymore
it is worth every penny to be in those
woods yeah you're literally five seconds
away from Center room it's not just
proximity it's trees it's everything
yeah everything about it is just great
and enjoy it because we won't be there
valuable and they took it from
it people would pay extra to be away
from us yeah all right so so he said go
ahead I'm sorry go ahead I'm sorry no I
just was gonna make another bad joke so
yeah but that no question that is the
most valuable piece of property on the
farm so then he continues his answer
there are a couple of options for a
similar experience and he goes into area
931 will offer a limited number of
primitive car camping including showers
air conditioned restrooms and other
amenities offering pre-pitched glamping
however you said all that and then Moon
Colony what is Moon Colony Moon Colony
will offer primitive camping option with
the same location VIP used to be with
shower vouchers and flushable toilets
included in those amenities so
whatever yeah I think this is a
reference to what Corey kind of hinted
last week when he said they have come up
with a whole naming scheme for the
campgrounds and it's all species yeah
yeah where I'm wearing area 931 Moon
Colony got it yeah got it where where
Moon quality colony is I don't know but
I'd say you're 100 right
Russian
yeah Moon colony is the same location as
VIP camping used to be got it and he
says we'll VIP camping even exists that
answer is the short answer is no VIP
camping won't exist as it has in the
past but there will be many more options
than available before and similar
experiences and folks will be able to
take advantage of
um
I'm going to assume that area 931 is
going to have camping available so as
you think of it in the past it will not
exist it will now be Moon colony which
is just another version of car camping
in GA but with some added amenities
um and then VIP camping moves back to
where we are number three there won't be
any lounges in the campgrounds but there
will be areas to relax the plaza as well
as expanded Lounge areas in Center route
for VIP GA plus and platinum buyers that
was to the question of will VIP still
have both camping and sinaroo dedicated
Lounge areas so the answer to that is no
but there will be areas to relax in the
plazas as well as expanded Lounge areas
in sinaroo forga plus VIP and platinum
buyers so and I'm jumping ahead a little
bit in this but in sort of interpreting
all of this what I'm gathering is
whereas before your wristband was very
limiting
you can only get here you know what I
mean it was you were blocked from going
here and even when you got out into
camping like I never went into VIP I've
never been inside of it would know what
it looked like never RV any of that if I
if I'm understanding it'll you'll be
much more able to mingle with anybody
like so say Brad gets VIP or gets RV or
whatever you know the glamping or the
pitch tent and and Russ and I don't we
can still go see you and vice versa
except for this area 931 that's the only
one that I think will still be off
limits
it does but I'm I'm trying to I'm trying
to think this through I wonder what it
matters if I get area 931 which is now
I'm guessing being called VIP then where
does platinum go
I've not seen any reference to platinum
well I mean he says platinum buyers okay
yeah well there's still a platinum
ticket but I don't think there's a
platinum Campground I think it's all
rolled into area 931 yeah and it doesn't
matter which ticket level you buy you
could you could purchase access to 931
even if you had a ga with all that being
said the ga ticket being the cheat is
cheaper than it was in 2023 right you
just have to then determine your
experience beyond that uh how you want
to experience a festival whether it be
in um in this part of the camp whether
with this experience that part is all up
to you but the basic GA pass is actually
cheaper than it was last year right
okay
all right
um I mean that that to me is is the most
confusing because it's different uh part
of this entire equation and and you know
what do we hate as human beings we hate
change yeah so this is one of those
things that you probably have to see in
practice before you wrap your head
around it and you're like oh wow this
actually was pretty good
um if they're offering you an
opportunity to and I would love to know
the price difference if they're offering
you the opportunity of camping back
where we used to Camp I don't know man
there might not be a price it's worth it
it's so good I mean I'm you name the
price I'm there
um we're gonna have to talk about that
in the next several weeks because uh
Russ and I both know where we were last
year and we're gonna have to we might
have to talk about it is it too late to
change my birthday present
podcast bank account we gotta sell a lot
more t-shirts
uh all right so then we get into
this question which is
one of the scenarios that was mentioned
last year was the eventually the
campground activities and shows May
continue to expand to the point where
they may sell a campground ticket
without buying a centeroo ticket
with all the new changes that allow for
this or will you still need a scenery
wristband to get through the toll booths
answer very simply you must still have a
centeroo ticket to enter the festival
and campgrounds meaning you cannot just
buy a campground ticket and hang out for
the weekend yeah that's not gonna happen
I think that was probably an idea that I
know I floated at one time I don't know
if we all did but I know I I don't know
if I meant it in jazz but it it was more
of a this what's happening out there in
camping is you know so cool and so busy
that this could happen so well then when
you get into sinaroo will there be
changes inside sinaroo for instance are
you going to change Pit access for GA
big question that's a huge yeah we got
that maybe a dozen times and his
response was quote this is important to
us too we are not changing that system I
do love their pit system that European
pit system where you you sort of you
know find your show and you line up for
for it and it's available to pretty much
anybody that wants to
to camp out for a few hours
especially when it's a light festival
it's so easy to get into the pit
um I almost wonder why somebody would
stand all the way out there when you
could just you know walk past the bees
and be there and you know
five minutes
um it really is a strange thing Barry is
one of these Taco that refuses to walk
into the pit I don't get it I've never
understood why you'd rather stand at the
back of the farm
I didn't walk another 40 yards and be 20
feet from the stage
I don't know I've never been a work my
way to the front of the stage fight my
way up guy because I hate when I do that
and then 40 people I you I get a good
spot and then 10 minutes later I'm still
40 rows back and I know that doesn't
happen in the pit because it's more
controlled but that's just been my
mindset the whole time I'd rather go
where well when you pull into a parking
lot do you drive to the front and look
for one up front or you take first
available
I'm not sitting in a car for an hour
watching a show where like my sight line
matters that is a ridiculous analogy
okay
well also I've done you have to pee what
do you do if you have to pee and and
Paul janeway's not around to pee on yeah
nice my personal porta potty is uh yeah
I'm looking for a party I'm looking for
Apollo party
nice call back that's good
hey uh I'm jumping again ahead but I've
reached out uh one of the questions that
we got that didn't make the early list
was about ADA and uh I sent that to uh
Corey and he just just responded so the
question freaking news yeah what about
what was the question remind me uh let's
see can you ask about ADA for your
follow-up last year Ada was okay but
access to activities in the campgrounds
was subpar I would like to know a bit
more about how they are looking to
rectify also what types of camping will
have Ada
um and then over there any changes to
Preferred viewing areas for VIP if they
expand that GA wristband folks uh and
then his answer is Ada base camp is the
same in the same location
it's very hard to provide proximity to
anything specifically other than
scenaroo with all the plazas being so
spread out so we prioritize scenaroo for
our Ada guests they'll be able to get RV
primitive car camping or souvenir in
that area there are many other areas
that will also offer accessible options
I'd like to encourage them to browse the
map with the accessible filter on to see
their options so oh a filter oh yeah
um you know
answers everything but uh sounds like
they're at least trying to figure
something out
and they don't exist don't anticipate
any changes to the premium viewing areas
from last year
so there you go thanks speaking of last
year this question was
what happens if we already purchased
tickets last year while we were at the
festival what we do now all you do now
is purchase your camping experience all
whatever can whatever camping package
that you want that's the only thing that
you'll have to go to add on to your
ticket now how they organize all that I
don't know
I mean that's that's on them but uh
that's all you will have to do is go to
choose your camping package when you um
when these things open up that's the
17th right
or is that the eight that's the AMA
well the 17th is when they put all this
on the website yeah
this is when they officially announce
what we've already been talking about
and then uh the 21st is first
and then they're going to have Black
Friday
will be their early bird sales for
tickets right is that what you
understood yeah yeah
and then from there on out it's you know
announcements in January lineup and all
that
plus real Clues real Clues
yep
um what other questions do we have I'm
just scrolling through here uh uh
anything else that we might have missed
um
somebody asked about whether it changes
capacity or any of that sort of who how
and I asked Corey that too when we were
talking like are you still gonna sell
more or less GA and I think Brad you
asked him that last week too or Brad
Parker
he said they're sort of limited uh you
know they're pre-pitch as they call them
is limited to availability of how many
tents they can get and sleeping bags and
everything so start wait a second start
over you mean capacity as far as the
whole festivals 80 000 is still sold out
um and as far as it like changing the
number of GA and all that it's still
going to be a similar
um
uh dispersion you know similar VIP
tickets and pre-pitch and all that to GA
um yeah
okay and then uh
what was the other one pick in your own
spot now that one is curious and I I
thought that when when it came up when
you asked the question Brad of Brad
Parker about if I get there and I don't
like my spot can I go to the other side
of the field
and uh
you know I I of course of course leave
it up to me to want to order off the
menu uh well well why can't I just do
what I want to do I have to be honest I
was surprised that Brad Parker's answer
that you can you know once they try to
put you in a spot you can go to the
other side of your Campground but you
can't go to another campground uh I'm
I'm betting the attendance and the guys
working there don't much like that
answer
they want you to go where they put you
because otherwise it'd just be
you know even more chaos but uh yeah
just tell them Brad said you could Brad
said I could not me not me don't quote
me on that one I have nothing to do with
it that's just my guess
um so so what was his answer here Corey
said honestly not too sure on this one I
think we usually prefer to have folks
Park we're instructed by the attendance
I think that it this is one of those
street smart things where you when you'd
show up and you're not a dick you say
hey man I've got 10 cars with me that
we're all going to camp together can we
just go over there yeah we're not going
to bother anybody yeah this is a this is
like if you've never been to Bonnaroo
before and look this is not a place that
is really really
um I don't know based on a lot of rules
yeah you know basically there's one rule
just be cool don't be a dick yeah don't
be a dick right and yeah if I can throw
in another top tip there when you show
up to Park and and you're talking to the
attendees if you've got a ice cold
bottle of water to hand them and be like
hey yeah be cool that goes a long way
yeah yes they're out working in the heat
they probably appreciate it it's so you
try water I give them a 20. yeah well
it's so funny to hear you talking about
this Brad's Diner were you there with me
Russ a couple of three years ago when he
came in late
and I'd already had it all worked out
and he walked in with his window and
he's like
yeah and me and the guy are looking at
each other like what's his problem
I'll have a conversation here yeah I'll
take care of this I just backed up and
said let him bent we'll figure it out
like I said I'd already worked it out
this kid was he was a 20 something year
old kid from Chattanooga he knew my
songbirds hat you know he was being I'll
just do whatever you want to do and then
here you drive up here I come I'm making
a fool of myself of course
there's no way this will work
yeah well we managed you got to count on
me to do one or two of those a weekend
I'm sure
Bigfoot my way up here
and of course as you know it can't but
nut butter we you know we take a butt
Nutter yes
maker so I mean we are speaking a lot so
speaking of butt Nutter uh I talked to
Brian Stone very early this morning
807 this morning you want to guess what
Brian stone is doing at 807 this morning
wow having a gem and tonic it was a gin
and juice he made a gin and juice and he
said he goes I've never heard of gin and
juice so I guess I just tried it
807. well you can't we took all day you
can't drink all day if you don't start
in the morning that's true that's true
all right okay all right um I know
there's gonna be more questions but you
know look we've got we got hundreds of
them we could only send a you know the
ones that seem to be the most asked to
Corey and not take up his entire day so
I hope that that is a good uh addendum
too uh last week's show and of course if
you haven't given it a shot it's a it's
a marathon I know it is a very long slog
last week
um but there was just a lot to get
through and of course when you get the
chitter chatter box like Russ Jackson
you can't just turn it off he's gotta
get you gotta let him go that's why we
had to do it hard long sorry we had to
do a two-parter but the key things are
if you bought GA already or if you
bought already you know you can still go
through the process right yeah the pit
area is still going to be there yes VIP
and all those sort of barriers outside
of centeroo are gone
uh Santa rue is where the VIP thing is
and you can sort of a la carte right I
mean what am I missing is that are those
the main things
the other thing too is like I know I
know VIP has always been a certain thing
but it always did make me like scratch
my head why they put where in the woods
an all-night rave party right next to
VIP who probably if I'm guessing is on
the older demographic and wanted to go
to bed early
um
where you are now where the I can't
stress this enough where VIP is going to
be now oh man it's worth every penny
it's worth it if you have the money
spend it the other thing I never oh
you're gonna sleep like a baby too the
only other thing that I never really
quite understood is that sort of barrier
like not being able to go visit friends
like not being able to have people come
visit us uh and not being able to go see
people in VIP even for us so I'm kind of
glad that's going away we'll see how it
works but really
yeah what do you mean by that I don't
know I don't know what you mean by that
I think that's what I understand this
whole thing is once you're outside
of Center room you're able to go to the
different areas I mean you could in some
some of the plazas but there were
barriers to some of the VIP and uh
glamping and all that if you didn't have
the right wristband you couldn't get to
it yeah but but you're not I don't
foresee you having a ga and a ga camping
experience being able to walk back to
VIP and area that's the one where you're
91 now that's the one right specifically
you can but I think you can in some of
the other areas yeah everything else I
think will be open that's right okay
that's why okay okay yeah and I really
really want to thank Corey and and Brad
again for
for doing this no I mean I think that
they're doing exactly the right thing
and they're trying to communicate as as
much and as often as possible
um and that's what look if there's one
been one complaint that we've had over
the last couple of years it's just the
the sheer and you know most of this
covid but the sheer lack of
communication about things that
um has really driven a lot of us you
know kind of crazy and and maybe turned
off a few folks I take this as a nice
step of them understanding hey this is a
this is going to be a big deal and this
is gonna you know make people readjust
and rethink and and really
address their pocketbook so good for
them for getting out in front of this
and trying to send as many smoke signals
up as possible that this is happening
this is happening and please don't uh
don't yell at us this time
why are you yelling I agree
I agree good all right um anything else
that we should get to
I think well I mean there's other news
that we'll probably get to the next
episode you know
um okay with some other events but the
big news again uh they're going to
announce on the 17th they're going to do
that ama on the 21st on uh social and
Discord uh so check your you know your
socials for the when and where and uh
then Rue Clues and then Black Friday and
then you know we're right back in it
yep so before they uh start getting the
lineup out there and I would like for us
to do our headline prediction show I
would like to
free of the information that we may or
may not have
uh I would like to like a predict the
lineup Headliners maybe top three lines
uh next episode what do you think okay
okay okay
yeah it's like to you know see what you
guys uh think is out there and then I'll
do the same all right because I'm gonna
go see one tonight that I feel as though
I know you are I feel like this could be
a real possibility of you know a
Saturday early eight o'clock slot yeah
um so all right all right I'll report
back and taco good luck man 25. it's a
good number you can do it you can do it
yeah
you're halfway there already my friend
I'm like Brian stone with my gym
laughs
all right all right by the way somebody
should donate his liver I don't know how
this dude has lived as long as he has
donate it and show this one off all
right we'll talk to you next week on the
podcast thanks guys
[Music]
consequence podcast Network